皆様、ほねほねザウルスご存知でしょうか。
どういうことかと言いますと
要するに簡単なプラモみたいなものです
8種類の恐竜が入ってて
こう中にプラモデルみたいなのが入ってるんですけど
これを組み立てて恐竜を作ります
わ、これめんどくさ
こんな感じです
こんな感じの恐竜が入ってるほねほねザウルスなんですけど
横を見てくれ！くみかえ・合体自由自在！！
たくさん集めて、自分だけのほねほねザウルスを作ろーう！
というわけで１００個集めました
どういうわけで、今回は
これほねほねザウルスを１００個集めたので
自分だけのほねほねザウルスを作ってみようと思います！
昔からの夢だった
これは昔からの夢だった！
ほねほねザウルス昔から好きだったんですけど
一回やりたかったんのよ～これ！
一回やりたかった～
１００個分のパーツを集めて、
どれだけ強力なほねほねザウルスが作れるのか
実際にやってみようと思います
では、行こう！
これはあのすごいブロックみたいに
くっつくんですよ
いやマジほねほねザウルスはね画期的だと思うよ
もうこういう感じにさっき出た恐竜ですらね
剣とか持たせれるんで
とにかくパーツがものすごい量あるので
ひとまず、全部出しましょう
めんどくさっ
これやばいな～時間との闘いな～これ多分
これ今日１日出来んのかな～
これなんか無理な気がしてきたんだけど
（パーツが外れる音）
ウワ―
これ多分ね、
１００個買うように計算されていないと思う
誰だよ！あなた恐竜じゃないよ
ちょっと時間が掛かりすぎるので
まぁ、だいたいこんな感じですね
組み立てると、こんな感じになることがわかったと思います
あのう、ちょっと組み立ててるとまじで多分１日終わっちゃうんで
パーツだけバラッともうバラッとします
組み立てません
では行こう！
手袋、手袋つけよう
ア――――
（泣き声）
きついよ（泣）
ちょっとなめてたな
やばい！これは
１日中ほねほねザウルスしか触ってないんですけど
待って、これまじできついんだけど
ホオーーー
でも多分、ここ乗り越えると絶対楽しいです
パーツさえあれば後は僕が好きなように作っていいんで
今が我慢時なんだ！
ここ乗り越えるしかない
ここ乗り越えれば、遊び放題！
頑張ります
とりあえず、出そう！
ラスト！
ハァ、ハァ
できたーーーー！
はい…
ハァハァハァハァ
ウオッ、コホ（咳）
という訳で無事、ほねほねザウルス100個開封しました
ちょっともうホントにめっちゃくちゃ時間かかる
どん位かな~
めっちゃ時間かかりました
普通に1個作ったら
こういう感じのほねほねザウルスが出来るんですけども
そのパーツが今、全部ここにあります
えーこれちょっと普通にさ面白そうなんだけど
いやーちょっと今回はちょっと苦痛の回だった
マジで辛かった
わあ…
すみません…
今日はここまでにしよう
ちょっともうマジできついっす
という訳で次回は、ここの部分全部外しとくんで
全てのパーツを使って
史上最強のほねほねザウルスを作ろうと思います
じゃあな！
ちょっと休憩